The statutes adopted by the states and upheld by the Supreme Court in 1976 the
most prevalent,
uh,
system that's used as a Wayne Statute,
like Florida had an Oklahoma had and,
uh,
California and others where the jury ways,
the aggravating factors against the mitigating factors.
Uh,
and,
and then the,
it's also the Georgia approach,
which is once the jury finds an aggravating circumstance,
uh,
it has complete discretion whether or not to impose the death pony or not.
Uh,
but Texas took a very different approach,
uh,
and it's death.
Plenty was upheld by the Supreme Court in 1976 in George versus Texas,
first of all,
Texas defined capital murder at the guilt phase of the trial,
that there were five different crimes that if you committed those crimes,
they were called capital murder.
And if a person was convicted of any one of those,
then the case went to the,
uh,
jury for a penalty determination.
And the jury was asked three questions.
Uh,
was it deliberate?
would the defendant be a future danger?
That is,
is there a probability that the defendant will commit acts of violence?
That would constitute a continuing threat to society.
And third,
was it reasonable in re in response to any provocation by the victim,
which usually doesn't apply.
Uh,
generally the first and the third didn't apply.
and so the case comes down to the jury's determination of future dangerousness.
Notice that what the jury's ask here is to find beyond a reasonable doubt that
there is a probability that the defendant will,
and of course the question comes,
what is a probability if there's a 20% probability that it will rain tomorrow,
as we are sometimes told,
uh,
is that a probability is if there's a 20% probability that the defendant will
commit future acts of violence?
Uh,
does that make the person eligible for the death pony?
Jurors are never really told the answer to that question.
Uh,
but it troubled some members of the Texas Court of criminal appeals when the
case was there,
but ultimately it was upheld by the Supreme Court and,
and injured versus Texas,
uh,
by the court comes back to a couple of questions that weren't answered then.
Uh,
and that's the question of psychiatrist testifying.
in these cases,
uh,
because what we're talking about here is the future,
not the past.
These are not,
uh,
all of our other aggravating circumstances look to the defendant had a record of
prior assaultive behavior or a prior,
uh,
murder conviction or sometimes they're descriptive.
Uh,
but this aggravating circumstance is basically a prediction of the future.
And the question becomes,
can you really do that?
And,
and if you can,
can you rely upon a mental health expert,
usually a psychiatrist,
but possibly a psychologist,
uh,
to make a prediction of how this person is going to behave in the future?
Well,
that'd became,
that's a controversial issue.
And it came to the Supreme Court,
uh,
in the case of a man named Thomas Barefoot.
Uh,
he was sentenced to death in Texas.
And normally,
only one psychiatrist testified if you were prosecuted in one part of Texas,
you'd be Dr Grigson would testify.
Uh,
another part,
doctor Holbrook would,
but for some reason they both testified,
uh,
and Thomas barefoots case,
too controversial parts of it.
One,
they never examined Thomas Barefoot.
Uh,
they just testified that he would be a future danger.
based on hypothetical questions that were asked,
uh,
by the prosecutor,
and,
um,
uh,
and then so too controversial things.
One,
the prediction itself.
And second,
based upon a hypothetical question,
without ever having met Thomas Barefoot,
given him any tests talked to him at all,
in this particular case,
the defense offered no evidence with regard to are no expert testimony with
regard to future dangerousness.
Uh,
this is Dr. James Grigson,
a trout all over Texas testified with sometimes testify and two or three cases
in the same week.
Uh,
and in,
uh,
Thomas barefoots case,
which sort of illustrates what this testimony was like,
he was asking a hypothetical question,
which incorporated all the facts of the crime that had been proven,
uh,
at the guilt phase.
Uh,
and then he testified with a reasonable and psychiatric certainty that barefoot,
uh,
was fairly classical typical,
so,
so pathic personality.
Uh,
secondly,
uh,
that he was in the most severe category of Solo SLAs.
Uh,
and,
uh,
that on a scale of one to 10,
barefoot was above a 10.
Now,
the jury and Thomas Barefoot is case.
Didn't know that this was a favorite little,
uh,
technique that Dr Grigson used whenever he testified or in many cases where he
testified to say on a scale of one to 10,
the person,
uh,
was over a 10.
Uh,
but you can imagine the impact that it would have on a jury,
uh,
in,
in hearing that testimony.
Uh,
and then he testified remarkably that there was a 100%,
uh,
an absolute a chance that he would commit future acts of violence.
This is what gets really controversial.
Can any doctor predict that,
um,
that a person is going to commit these future acts of violence that will make
them a continuing threat to society?
Well,
at the Habeas Corpus hearing was held later,
uh,
and both sides put on evidence with regard to this question.
The state put on Dr. George Parker.
He was a psychologist and Dr Coons who was a psychiatrist and they testified,
first of all that accurate predictions can be made,
uh,
that psychiatrists can make predictions.
Uh,
and second,
uh,
one who fills the,
has the characteristics summed up in the hypothetical question asking Thomas
barefoots case,
uh,
is a person who would commit future acts of violence?
Well,
barefoot puts on a some testimony as well.
First he has doctor Faison,
who's a psychiatrist and he says,
no doctor should be giving a diagnosis based simply on a hypothetical question.
He said,
one of my medical students comes to me and he says,
here's what,
and he tells me three or four things about the person.
I may make a tentative diagnosis,
uh,
but I'm going to see that patient,
examine the patient,
talk to the patient before I make a diagnosis.
A Dr. Dickerson testified,
uh,
that,
no reliable prediction can ever be made.
That it's just simply not possible to predict whether somebody's going to be
violent,
uh,
in the future or not.
Uh,
and then in fact,
people are wrong two times out of three when they try to make those predictions.
Uh,
and finally,
a doctor Moynihan,
who thought when he started working on it that it was not possible to predict
future dangerousness.
He comes to the conclusion that it may be that in some circumstances a
prediction may be possible,
uh,
and maybe ethically appropriate because one of the questions that was raised in
the American psychiatric association was whether or not it was ethical for
psychiatrists to be testifying about this.
Um,
so the questions presented to the court in the barefoot case,
is it reliable?
Uh,
and the court has said that because death is different because the death plenty
is unlike any other penalty,
there's a greater need for reliability and whether or not to impose the death.
Pauline.
Secondly,
can you have this testimony based just on hypothetical questions,
uh,
without any examination of the defendant.
Now,
the reason there was no examination of the defendant is the supreme court had
held in an earlier case,
uh,
that unless,
the person was given their Miranda warnings.
Uh,
and unless the lawyer was notified,
uh,
these kind of impersonal examinations,
which Dr Grigson used to do,
a,
we're not permissible.
Once that happened,
that pretty much ended,
uh,
access,
by the psychiatrist,
uh,
to the defendants if the defendant were to call his own psychiatrist.
And have that psychiatrists do an examination,
then the state would be entitled to do an examination.
But most of the time there's not going to be an examination later.
Uh,
the question will come up whether or not group characteristics can you base the
future dangerousness on ethnicity or race.
But we'll get to that later.
Right now we look at these first two questions,
uh,
that the supreme court is asked to decide.
Let's go back to the testimony and doctor [inaudible] and Dr. Thomas Barefoot
case by doctor,
Doctor Grigson.
Uh,
he was asking about these studies,
uh,
both doctors where he was asking about these studies demonstrating that a future
predictions of future dangerousness are often unreliable.
Uh,
Dr Griggs and said,
well,
there are a few people that think that it's a minority group within the
profession and it's certainly not the American psychiatric association that
believes that.
Well,
and the barefoot case,
uh,
the American psychiatric association files a brief to the supreme court and its
brief says,
uh,
that the unreliability of these predictions,
for longterm future dangerousness is clearly a established as a unreliable
within the profession.
Uh,
and that two out of three predictions are wrong.
So the question comes up to the court,
are we going to allow this testimony even though it's wrong?
Two Times out of three,
the Supreme Court says yes and an opinion by justice white for the majority,
uh,
sort of says at the very start looking back to Jurich,
this is almost like asking us to reinvent the wheel.
Um,
it's a little something of an odd statement to make because what really was an
issue here was the reliability of the evidence that was coming in,
uh,
with regard to this.
Um,
the fact that it is a difficult one.
Justice white says,
doesn't mean that it can't be made.
Uh,
he said it's made another context.
and it is with regard to,
uh,
committing people to mental health institutions.
Usually that's based on the expert testimony of a psychiatrist,
uh,
that the person is a danger to themselves or others.
Uh,
whether or not someone's released is based upon a prediction of whether when
released there'll be a danger to themselves or others.
Uh,
also,
uh,
with regard to preventative detention,
which is to be very rare,
but now it's more common in criminal cases.
But again,
this involves a fairly short period of time.
Uh,
preventive detention is detaining a person pending their trial instead of
releasing them on bail.
And it's based on a determination that the court thinks the person may be a
danger to the community or it will be a danger to the community and therefore
they're held in jail as opposed to allow a released.
Um,
uh,
finally,
diagnosis as a sociopath,
uh,
based on prior behavior.
He says,
if you,
if you can say looking at what this person has done,
that they have acted as a sociopath,
a,
then you can say that in the future.
Uh,
he goes on to say basically,
and here's where the case,
uh,
the ultimate holding in the case,
let the adversary system sorted out.
We'll let the prosecution puts on its evidence and the defense can cross
examine.
It,
can bring out these studies if it wants to.
It can put on its own experts.
Uh,
but the jury often in a case gives more credence to one expert than another.
nothing wrong with that.
And so we'll let the jury's a sorted out.
Of course.
The question here is how does the jury sorted out?
How do they do that?
Is it depend on if you've got a witness like doctor Grigson who even though what
he was saying was not approved by the American Psychiatric Association,
uh,
but very articulate,
very charismatic,
uh,
has this way of testifying that really connected with jurors.
Um,
and then of course prejudices and,
uh,
about psychiatry and the law and crime and so forth.
Uh,
do those come into play?
Well,
the close case,
uh,
justice Blackmun dissented joined by Justice Brennan and Marshall,
basically saying the court has got to act as a gatekeeper.
We can't let evidence that's wrong.
Two out of three times,
uh,
come before juries.
Uh,
he points out that not a single reputable,
reputable scientific source confirms or says,
uh,
that future dangerousness is acceptable.
They all agree that it's going to be wrong two times out of three.
Uh,
and so he's concerned about the risk that the death penalty will be imposed
because the jury will be incapable of separating this myth from reality.
And that in fact the,
the,
the predictions of future dangerousness two out of three times are not even
going to be accurate.
So the jury is going to be relying upon a inaccurate information,
very important case,
uh,
because allowing this testimony in and allowing Dr Grigson and others to
testify,
uh,
this is one reason why so many people have been sentenced to death in Texas.
Uh,
once you get to the penalty phase,
the jury was asked these three questions.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
If the answer all three questions,
Including this future dangerousness one,
then the person sentence sentenced to death.
There's not nearly the flexibility in Texas a and it wasn't until the later
case,
which we'll get to.
Uh,
there was very little flexibility for the jury once it found those three things
is deliberate future danger to society.
Uh,
and that the victim of the crime,
uh,
did not provoke,
the defendant and the response was a appropriate for provocation,
which is I said to sell,
I'm going to be an issue in a case.
Well,
how reliable is this evidence?
Judge Garcia,
a judge on the United States Court of Appeals for the fifth circuit,
uh,
takes a look at it in a concurring opinion in a case called Flores versus
Johnson.
Uh,
he looks at another doctor who testifies regularly with regard to future danger.
Clay Griffith,
uh,
he's testified 22 times for the state of Texas and he's always found future
danger every single time.
So I guess,
uh,
whether or not you can predict future dangerousness or not,
you can certainly predict how Dr. Griffin will testify with regard to future
dangerousness.
He's always going to say,
uh,
and again,
he testifies based on hypothetical questions.
Uh,
Judge Garza points out that if you look at what the federal courts,
the standards set by a case called Dahlberg vs Merrell Dow Pharmaceuticals,
uh,
as a case,
not a constitutional case,
but a case based on what evidence is admissible in the federal courts.
And it's set up a five part test that judges were to use before allowing a
expert testimony to come in.
Uh,
he looks at it,
no testing of the theories have been done here.
Uh,
that was one of the requirements,
uh,
under,
under Dow.
Um,
the extent to which has been peer review.
Well,
there's been peer review,
a future dangerousness,
but it's all been negative.
Uh,
so that would be a factor for exclusion.
the rate of error is greater than 50%.
In fact,
it's two out of three,
um,
standards of controlling and testing or nonexistent normally for evidence to
come in.
There has to be some way to have controls and standards in terms of how this
evidence comes,
comes in.
Uh,
and finally,
instead of being accepted in the scientific community,
which is required for evidence to come and in federal courts,
uh,
it's been uniformly rejected by the scientific community.
So why is it still allowed a while the,
uh,
he points out one of the thing that I should mention,
you're making a prediction without even meeting the defendant is seen as
inherently unreliable,
unscientific,
and unethical.
Uh,
Dr. Griffin said here that there was no remorse because there was no evidence,
uh,
from which he could deduce remorse.
But of course,
he'd never talked to the man.
So how would he know if there was any remorse or not?
Uh,
so why doesn't a doctoral Griffin's testimony?
Why isn't it excluded?
It's unreliable.
He didn't examine the person,
uh,
in person.
It's not accepted under any of the five factors in the Daubert case.
And yet a Daubert applies to the federal courts.
It does not to Texas.
The ultimate decider of what evidence is at middle,
admissible in Texas courts is the Texas Court of criminal appeals and the Texas
Supreme Court.
But it's not,
uh,
the,
the Daubert standards not been adopted,
uh,
in Texas a and the Fifth Circuit Court of Appeals,
the court that decided the forest case,
uh,
it's bound by the barefoot case.
So if Texas allows this testimony,
then,
uh,
then it's going to be upheld.
And Flores Dustin's is affirmed by the court.
Um,
now we come to Victor Sal Domino's case.
Uh,
in this case,
the psychiatrist Doctor [inaudible] testifies that Sodano is a future danger in
part of that's based on the circumstances of the crime.
Uh,
and,
uh,
his,
again,
we have lack of remorse testified to by Dr who never examined him.
But what's controversial is he also testifies that there's the testicle
likelihood based on 24 factors that he will be a future danger.
And one of those factors,
uh,
is that Sodano is Hispanic.
So he's saying that he,
we know he's more likely to be with future danger because he's Hispanic.
The defense lawyer fails to object.
Uh,
so the Texas Court of Criminal Appeals,
uh,
says it's waived.
The Texas attorney general,
that time later,
Senator John Cornyn,
uh,
confessors era in all the cases in which doctor Akil Hano has testified,
saying we can't allow people to go to death row based upon a expert testimony
that they're more dangerous because of their ethnicity or their race.
Uh,
and even though the state confessors era,
the Texas Court of criminal appeals rejects it,
uh,
in the Sodano case,
ultimately the federal courts grant relief to people who have been sentenced in
this way,
except for one man,
Dwayne Buck.
Uh,
Dwayne buck was,
uh,
again,
doctor to Ohana and testified,
and he said that African Americans like Duane buck were statistically more
likely than the average person to engage in crime.
But the wrinkle in this case is that he was called nod by the prosecution to put
this evidence on,
but by Dwayne Bucks,
lawyer by the defense.
Um,
so the question becomes,
are we going to set the case aside anyway,
a or not a supreme court denies review of the case Justice Alito,
uh,
rights saying that if it hadn't been for the fact that the defense lawyer
presented this,
uh,
we wouldn't,
we would reverse this case.
Um,
justice Sotomayer joined by Justice Kagan says a Texas admitted era in two other
cases where the defense lawyer call this doctor,
uh,
and the prosecutor ask about race on cross examination and later referred to it
in closing argument.
Um,
finally,
what about future dangerousness?
Justice Marshall points out that in the case of Wilbert Lee Evans here since to
death in Virginia,
which also uses a future,
dangerousness is an aggravating factor.
That's the only basis for sentencing him to death.
While he's on death row,
there's an escape attempt.
In fact,
it's an a successful escape attempt.
Uh,
and while that's going on,
uh,
he,
six inmates involved in that,
uh,
Evans took decisive steps,
to calm the riot.
He saved several of the hostages.
He prevented the rape of a nurse.
And over the time that he was in a prison in Texas,
uh,
his,
behavior was exemplary.
Uh,
and so justice Marshall says,
the sole basis for syncing this man to death,
that he was a future danger is dead wrong.
Not only was he not a future danger,
uh,
he took heroic steps,
to save lives and prevent sexual assault on this nurse.
Uh,
nevertheless,
uh,
governor wilder,
Virginia did not commute the sentence.
Uh,
Wilbur Lee Evans was executed by the state of Virginia.
he said that,
uh,
Justice Marshall's dissent,
gave him great comfort.
He,
he wrote on it,
bury me with this and put it in his pocket right before he went into the
execution chamber.
Uh,
so future dangerousness continues,
uh,
to be used,
in,
in some states,
a handful,
not that many.
Uh,
but certainly in Texas,
which of course carries out far more executions than any other state.
And has a large number of people sentenced to death,
very controversial,
but allowed in the courts.
And,
uh,
cases like Evans,
may make us think twice about it.